in this lecture we'll continue our
discussion of continuous random
variables we will start by bringing
conditioning into the picture and
discussing how the PDF of a continuous
random variable changes when we are told
that a certain event has occurred we
will take the occasion to develop
counterparts of some of the tools that
we developed in the discrete case such
as the total probability and total
expectation theorem in fact we will push
the analogy even further in the discrete
case we looked at the geometric PMF in
some detail and recognized an important
memorylessness property that it
possesses in the continuous case there
is an entirely analogous story that we
will follow this time involving the
exponential distribution which has a
similar memorylessness property we will
then move to a second theme which is how
to describe the joint distribution of
multiple random variables we did this in
the discrete case by introducing joint
pmfs in the continuous case we can do
the same using appropriately defined
joint PDFs and by replacing sums by
integrals as usual we will illustrate
the various concepts through some simple
examples and also take the opportunity
to introduce some additional concepts
such as mixed random variables and joint
cumulative distribution functions